et on continue de parler de cette
attaque à l'armé blanche matin dans les
rues de paris avec le journaliste denis
demonpion ce bonjour denis demonpion ce
merci d'être avec nous cet après midi
sur rt france vous l'avez vu avec nous
dès attaques qui ont une nouvelle fois
ciblée des journalistes ou écouter
j'entends les réactions beaucoup
évidemment par de la liberté de la
presse la liberté d'expression etc etc
ces bonbons mais il faut pas perdre de
vue que quand même c'est avant tout et
d'après les premiers éléments de
l'enquète que c'est quand même un
attentat islamiste est essentiel de le
dire et de le répéter et de le souligner
parce que quand on écoute les propos
lénifiants jean castex c'est pas à la
hauteur de ce genre d'attentât
d'ailleurs poursuivre le procès charline
actuellement et de l'hyper cacher je
vois bien que il y as en envoie bien au
style des audiences qu'il y a un petit
peu une une peur une crainte à nommer
les choses et c'est le grand malheur de
ces attentats qui sont perpétrés au nom
d'allah de mahomet de l'islam radical
etc etc
alors depuis quelques temps le poseur la
république qui est très frileux sur ces
questions nous annonce du bout des
lèvres une loi sur le séparatif mais en
réalité pauvres pour lutter contre le
séparatisme
mais en réalité c'est pas ça il ya ni
les bretons ni les causes ni les basques
ni les auvergnats ne parle de
séparatisme en fait on sait très bien
qu'aujourd'hui le problème majeur c'est
que il y à une fraction de la population
d'ailleurs qui pour certains est
totalement immigrés etc
et d'ailleurs
semble que l'un des agresseurs
aujourd'hui soit un pakistanais je
rappelle quand même que le pakistan a
été le premier à protester violemment
véhémentement encontre charlie quand ils
ont republié les caricatures de mahomet
ya quinze jours trois semaines donc je
pense qu'il serait urgent pour ce
gouvernement de prendre les décisions
qu'ils imposent de lutter contre les
mouvements extrémistes salafistes les
frères musulmans d'ailleurs il ya des
pays où ils sont interdits
mais la france c'est curieusement reste
les bras ballants en tout cas denis
demonpion cette attaque n'a toujours pas
été revendiqué un par des réseaux
terroristes islamistes et puis la
préfecture de police 1 n'a toujours pas
confirmé qu'il s'agissait d'un attentat
terroriste islamiste
non mais vous savez il ya eu plusieurs
agressions de ce type alors pas aussi
spectaculaires que celles aujourd'hui
mais de plus en plus des types commettre
des agressions au couteau
revendiquant à la etc
et à chaque fois enfin en tout cas c'est
quelqu'un allait dernière fois et
l'aimer c'est de dire que ce sont des
déséquilibrés alors moi je veux bien que
le fanatisme
souad soit un déséquilibre mais enfin le
gouvernement se sont au regret de
prendre les choses à bras le corps et de
traiter le problème efficacement le fait
que des journalistes soient une nouvelle
fois
visé est ce que vous pensez que les
journalistes ne sont pas assez protégés
en france non écoutez je pense que je
heureusement il n'y a pas deux trois
policier derrière chaque journaliste il
ya des journalistes de faire l'idiot qui
sont toujours menacées qui sont toujours
sous haute protection
c'est le cas de ginette qui a témoigné
l'autre jour de manière absolument
bouleversante au procès et qui est une
femme qui de ce point de vue là ne se
ment pas et part d'expériences des
menaces qu'elle reçoit mais vous savez
la manière dont la société gangrénée ça
se voit aussi quand vous avez des jeunes
filles à strasbourg nord-est de la
france qui sont agressées parce qu'elles
portent des jupes
donc il ya un problème de comment
dirais-je de volonté pour les agresseurs
d'imposer leur rôle leur loi de ne pas
tolérer l'égalité homme femme de vouloir
imposer la charia
enfin il ya eu il ya quelques années la
fondation montaigne qui avait fait une
étude très intéressante et très poussées
et approfondie sur ce phénomène là à
l'époque il disait qu'il y avait quelque
chose comme 12000 salafistes en france
et il n'a qu'à 75% qui voulait la charia
plutôt que les lois de la république
encore récemment charlie hebdo a publié
au début du procès a fait un sondage là
dessus ils disent que chez les musulmans
- 25 ans il y en a 75 % ce qui est
considérable qui poursuit der que en
effet si la charia s'applique est ça
serait pour leur plus grand bonheur
ça pose un sérieux problème il ya une
atteinte caractérisée à la république et
à ses valeurs
denis demonpion le parquet
antiterroriste était saisi
pour cette affaire qu'est ce que vous
attendez justement de cette enquête au
parquet antiterroriste
déjà que le parquet que la police et
comment dirais-je arrête les
responsables et fasse la lumière sur les
complicités aussi car on sait bien que
après la taclant et après ça allez dire
là la réaction qui avait les réactions
qui avait été prise pour est
effectivement un peu plus haut niveau au
niveau des robes finement j'ai un gros
surveiller ces mouvements là on a bien
vu qu'il a pris il n'y avait plus que
les agressions j'allais dire d'individus
mais souvent les individus n'agissent
pas complètement seul il s'avère qu'ils
sont 1 2 ou 3 puisque après les
attentats charlie puis le bataclan en
2015 puis l'hyper cacher aussi on a bien
vu que il y avait quelque chose il
fallait se mobiliser pour lutter contre
ça et vous savez des attentats ya celui
d'aujourd'hui il celui au sein de la
préfecture
souvenez vous il ya eu quand même quatre
morts
eh bien on a toujours l'impression après
tant de drames de deux morts et puis je
ne parle pas de tous les gens qui reste
blessé au pied et on aura l'occasion de
le voir au procès du bataclan quand les
auteurs en tout cas ceux qui ont survécu
sont jugé qu' il ya des gens qui on le
voit aujourd'hui au procès charlie heins
quand les gens viennent témoigner c'est
à dire qu'ils aient été victimes le jour
de l'attentât victime directe dans leur
chair ou simplement témoins
mais ce sont des gens qui sont détruits
et brisé et qui ne s'en remettent pas
merci
coût denis demonpion d'avoir été avec
nous cet après midi sur rt frange
rappelle que vous êtes journaliste on